I have not received a massage before in
fact I don't really enjoy human contact
I have not given a massage to a male
friend before I'm comfortable getting a
massage from a male friend this will
definitely be weird I just hope I give a
good massage step are you breathing on
me dude what are you ticklish yeah I'm
ticklish this will be fun let the games
begin
put on me that towel let me lay that
across his groin
it's good story yeah sure you suppose so
you whose secret to a good oiling oh oh
oh do it
oh my what's the tension added to your
shoulders I think the tension is between
us so much hair I am glad that your
hairless though I don't know why this
seems like it would be weirder if you
had hair perks of a giving a massage in
Asian guy I guess it feels like a
tarantula made out of hot dogs is trying
to burrow into the back of my skull I'm
just trying not to look at your face
kind of on cloud nine right now this was
kind of great he might just start
strangling I think that's every man's
fear is that one another man is
massaging them that they're just going
to decide to murder them really there's
no back massages no I shaved my back for
today so it would if it was a weird
continue you get to be game yesterday
maybe it's just that I'm domed to the
horror of what's happening to me but you
know this is I don't hate well we did it
I feel very relaxed now I feel like an
angel I kind of enjoy giving massages
it felt simultaneously comfortable and
uncomfortable at the same time not as
creepy as I expected giving a massage to
a guy where massage brothers now highest
level of friendship this is okay I
wouldn't do very enough yeah I
understand why not so same time next
week